encontré un comentario en el vídeo
pasado de este ordenamiento por
inserción que decía que no tenía
necesariamente que hacer break aquí y
este es un ejemplo de esas veces que uno
está programando algo y depende de la
manera en la que el cerebro esté
pensando en eso uno no lo hace
necesariamente de la manera más elegante
y ese comentario era correcto hay una
manera más elegante de hacer este
ordenamiento por inserción entonces en
esta parte del ciclo while vamos a ver
qué pasa aquí
este ciclo while se ejecuta mientras i
sea mayor o igual que 0 y lo que quiero
esencialmente es salir del ciclo si la
variable valor no es menor que lo que
está en el elemento i de la lista así
que voy a ver una mejor manera de
hacerlo porque realmente lo que estoy
haciendo aquí es definir los parámetros
para poder ejecutar las instrucciones
que están en este ciclo y en lugar de
hacer este if si lo que está en valor es
menor que el elemento i de la lista hace
esto y si no ejecuta este break lo que
pude haber hecho y qué
una manera un poco más elegante de hacer
esto es while y mientras si es mayor o
igual a 0 y valor es menor que el
elemento i de la lista esto sigue siendo
lo mismo que antes pero ahora sé qué
valor es menor que el elemento i de la
lista ya no tengo que ejecutar este
código que tengo aquí porque ahora sé
que esto va a ser verdadero y voy a
poner esto un poco más a la izquierda un
nivel a la izquierda y luego ya no tengo
que hacer ningún else y no tengo que
hacer break y esto simplificará un poco
el programa pero vamos a verificar que
esto realmente funciona déjenme salvarlo
y correrlo se ve bien déjenme definir
una lista que voy a llamar se hice es
igual a 1
5 6 7 24 14 y 2 y ahora voy a llamar a
la función de ordenamiento por inserción
ordenamiento por inserción en c
ok déjenme imprimirse print ce y aquí
vemos que está bien está ordenada
gracias por el comentario
creo que esto simplificó un poco la
función siempre tenemos que preguntarnos
especialmente cuando usamos este ciclo
while si hay una mejor manera de salir
en lugar de ser break porque yo puse
break en una condición que podría estar
implícita en esta parte de aquí